Chut
n'aie pas peur tu peux faire un
sourire à maman bisous de bonne nuit
es-tu toujours très triste c'est normal
tu veux parler de tes parents et de
ton frère ça va prendre du temps pour lui
trouver une famille d'accueil
on peut l'emmener
don'  ne sois pas surpris si elle est en retrait
difficile je sais que ça ressemble à un
cauchemar mais un jour ça pourrait être mieux
tu verras tu vas
bien c'est pour moi
je fais bouger les objets quand je pleure maman
papa ce n'est pas de ta faute si de mauvaises choses
arrivent n'est-ce pas  venir jouer leurs
empreintes digitales de plusieurs enfants partout
dans la maison et les feuilles sont parmi
eux que pensez-vous que Nivas a fait vous
pensez qu'elle a assassiné toute une famille
vous allez bien oui c'est impossible vous avez
vu ce qu'elle a fait
vous parlez aux enfants maintenant ce qu'ils
dit à l'école qu'ils ne réalisent pas à quel
point si je dois être
puni tu me donnes Dieu je suppose